This video is sponsored by Squarespace
Whether you need a domain website or online store make it with Squarespace
I think it'd be fair to say that I am known on YouTube as the guy who?
Makes videos about how he got his PhD and I feel like my videos may have
disproportionately
Encouraged and motivated people to want to do phd's
I'm not sure how I feel about that so as an addendum to my PhD vlog series. I wanted to make this
Honest video outlining precisely why you prospective student at home?
should not
apply for a PhD
firstly money if you look at the average career earnings for graduates who have PhDs and compare them to
Graduates who just have undergraduate degrees those with PhDs earn
26% more in total across their careers
Which sounds pretty good, right?
You know it's more money
But if you compare the average career earnings for graduates who have master's degrees with those who just have undergraduate degrees
those with master's own
23% more on average
than someone with just an undergraduate degree so PhD graduates do earn more than those with master's degrees and with undergraduate degrees but
not much more than people who just did a
Masters and they spent three or four more years in education further to this PhD graduates who leave academia and move into
Industry face an awful lot of misconceptions about what having a PhD?
Means they get pigeonholed they get accused of being over specialized get questions like if you have a PhD
Why aren't you applying to be a professor if you have a PhD you ask me some kind of urban nerd I'm not going to
Employ you you must not be able to talk to people and then during a PhD you earn
Extremely little certainly compared to people that you
graduated on your same uni course with and you weren't extremely little for an awful lot of work in my
Final year of my PhD I was doing 12-hour days all the time during the last few months. I wouldn't take a day off for
Months at a time how about social factors during a PhD you often work completely alone?
You can spend day after a day just working on your own never talk to anyone
Just writing and writing and writing on a laptop
And if you're unfortunate enough to have an inattentive
Supervisor you can be left completely
adrift by them and not have any clue what you're supposed to be doing you have a much higher probability of
Developing mental health problems during a PhD good luck trying to maintain a healthy social life a healthy relationship
A healthy work-life balance a healthy sleeping schedule health during my PhD I developed
Psychosomatic breathing problems meaning my mental health had deteriorated to the point where I couldn't
Physically breathe and those PhD students that do make it through all of that and stay in academia
then face years and years of low pay long hours and
Changing city every couple of years to chase new jobs the early stages of an academic career are a constant grind of
teaching and research and relocation what I'm saying is you shouldn't apply for a PhD if you value money or
Prestige or power or a comfortable life. Why on earth would anyone willingly sign up to do a PhD
Because they're passionate about something
There are plenty of negatives about doing a PhD and there are lots of reasons why you shouldn't do one
But really this video should be called why you should do the PhD
but that will get way fewer views despite having identical information in it so
Got a play on those psychological factors to answer the question of why you should do a PhD you have to ask
What is a PhD a PhD is an opportunity to?
Push the envelope of human knowledge a tiny bit and learn stuff
That nobody else has ever learned before it's an opportunity funded to a certain minimum amount
Enough money to make sure that you can live and you can learn these new things
but no more than that and
then in exchange for that funding the only thing you need to do is when you do learn something new and you do push the
boundaries of human knowledge
you
Publish it in such a way that other people can benefit from what you've learned too in this sense a PhD is like a contract
Society invests in you and you then provide a return on that investment in the form of a better understanding of
something so you should apply for a PhD if you're passionate about something and
You think that spending three or four years of your life at this stage in your life doing nothing?
But that thing is the best use of your time on earth
It's that simple don't apply for a PhD if you want to earn lots of money
Because you're not gonna earn much more money than if you just did a masters
Don't apply for a PhD if you want some swanky job
That's what you're shooting for because yes, I should mention that some jobs do ask for a PhD
That's a fair point but for an awful lot of jobs it sometimes seems that having a PhD is a disadvantage
Apply to do a PhD if you are passionate about something academic because you need that passion
Otherwise you won't survive you have to be able to
Happily, see yourself doing the thing you're passionate about
Every day for three or four years and then even those people that go into a PhD with that conviction
Still hate their PhD by the end of it and a lot of those people who go in with that conviction still
Drop out halfway through the PhD because the difficulties like I mentioned earlier are immense
Every single person I've spoken to at the end of their PhD was desperate for it to be done
They were just done with the whole thing and that even includes
Professors when I asked them about their PhDs
They were desperate to be finished by the end of it
I interviewed a bunch of PhD
Supervisors at my union couple of years ago and asked them what they looked for in a PhD students
here are a few of their answers a
PhD student has to have the technical background to in the area of study
Which which is a given if they're up if they're applying, but what I like to see is PhD students?
Who are enthusiastic about the topic that?
That they're gonna be studying and are ready to get going on it and genuinely want to push the frontiers of knowledge
And they want to go out and share it, okay, if you if you're thinking of applying for a PhD
Ask yourself a question why you would
Like to do that and if the answer is because you're really interested in the topic and you're really interested in doing research on that
topic then do a PhD
Don't do it because you think it's a good. You know these days. I look for people that are
Quite focused but also have a going to drive
To understand things they kind of get research it excites them
No, everyone does mean some people do research because they think this is sort of what we do
I'm a club
I did a good degree we come to do a PhD and they just think
They never really get it and there was no light goes on a no point do they either think this is really frustrating which is
Okay, it should be frustrating or this is really exciting they just think
boring this and they're not cared for research that bright people don't kind of reserved so ask yourself if
You've been inspired by my videos, or if you're thinking about doing a PhD
Seriously, ask yourself
Why do you want to do this?
What do you value?
Do you think that spending the next three or four years of your life?
Following what you're passionate about doing what you really enjoy doing
It's the best use of your time at this point in your life
or
Do you value money more or power or prestige or a comfortable life more if you do?
That's absolutely fine
But you shouldn't apply for a PhD
Whoa everything got a little bit real there
I felt like I had to make this video in order to think of myself as a responsible
Educational youtuber I think it's great that people watch my videos and they want to do a PhD
But I think it's super important that people understand what they're letting themselves in for which I think they probably do get from the vlogs
but also what having a PhD does for you what it means because
I've definitely been seeing a lot of comments recently from people that really misunderstand. What a PhD is before
so
everything got very real here much much more so than on my channel normally, but I
Think this is important
And I hope that it that it's useful to some people if you've watched a whole bunch of educational content on YouTube
Which if you're watching my channel you almost certainly have then you know what comes next
Next we have me recommending use some products or service
Giving you a link of some kind and then moving on to a final video summary or evaluation in this case though
This is super easy for me because I've been sponsored by a company that I've been personally using
For ages and they're Squarespace I've been using Squarespace to host my website simonoxfphys.com for
Months and it's a hub for everything I do so it you know my podcast my videos and in the future
I'm going to be putting my PhD thesis on there once
I've finished my Corrections and when I do put my thesis online. I know it's going to be incredibly easy
It's probably gonna
Take me all of 30
Seconds to upload my thesis and put it on my website as a matter of fact when I set up my website early this month
to start handling merchandise
I
genuinely
Couldn't believe how easy it was I personally recommend it to anyone who wants to sell merchandise online or just have your own website
It's it's honestly that good if you have a project that you're passionate about and you want to build a website for it
That's gonna
Look great and be super easy to run
Then go to Squarespace.com for a free trial and then when you're ready to launch go to Squarespace.com/Simon Clark
to get 10% off your first website or domain Thank You Squarespace for sponsoring me
it's super easy to recommend your product because I use it and I think it's great and
Thank you for watching this video. I would say that I hope it doesn't put you off applying for a PhD but I
Kind of do for some people I think it's important that you understand what having a PhD
Means for you and what you're letting yourself in for by applying for one actually on that subject if you haven't seen them already
definitely check out my PhD Vlogs up there somewhere and
Thank you again for watching the video if you enjoyed it, too
Please give it a like and if you're not subscribed to the channel consider subscribing
I'll see you in the next one